we've now laid the groundwork so we can
express this surface integral which is
the right-hand side of the way we've
written stoke's theorem we can now
express this as a double integral over
the domain of the parameters that we
care about and we're going to do that in
this video and then in the next series
of videos we'll do the same thing for
this expression we're actually going to
do that using green's theorem what we're
going to do is we're going to see we get
the same expressions which will show us
that stoke's theorem is true at least
for this special class of surfaces that
we are studying right here but they're
pretty general
now let's now try to do that so our
surface integral i'm just going to
rewrite it down here it's the surface
integral
so over our surface of the curl of f
actually let me go a little bit lower
so we have our surface integral
surface integral
of the curl of f
curl of f
dot
d s dot
d s well we've already figured out what
our curl of f is here two videos ago and
we've almost figured out what d s is d s
is a cross product of these two vectors
times d a the cross product of these two
vectors is this right over here so we
could just write that d s
d s is going to be equal to this thing
times
d a this is the cross product of the
partial of r with respect to x and the
partial of r with respect to y and then
we have to multiply that times d a right
over there so this expression is just
going to be the dot product the dot
product of the curl of f which is
this stuff up here dotted with this
stuff down here and essentially we're
going to take the dot product of this
vector and that vector and then multiply
it times this we can actually consider
this to be a scalar value so let's do
that so this is going to be equal to and
when we do this all of these we're now
going to start operating in the domain
of our parameters so it's going to turn
from a surface integral into a double
integral over that domain over that
region that we care about this is the
domain of our parameters this region r
and this is how we've how we've
able to this is how we've manipulated
any of the surface integrals that we've
come across so far we've turned them
into
double integrals over the domain of the
parameters so this is going to turn into
a double integral
over the domain of our parameters which
is the region r it's the region r in the
x y plane right up here
and now we can take the dot product of
the curl of f with d dotted d s which is
all of this business right over here let
me see if i can show both of them on the
screen at the same time there you go so
first let's think about the x components
so you have that right over there and
then you have this right over here you
multiply the two the negative we can
swap the order right over there you have
the partial of z with respect to x
times and we're going to swap this order
right over here the partial of q with
respect to z minus the partial of r with
respect to y
now let's think about
now let's think about the
j component you have negative z sub y
times all of this up here at least the
stuff that's multiplied times the j
component this negative can cancel out
with that negative so you have plus
z sub y the partial of z with respect to
y
times the partial of r with respect to x
minus the partial of p with respect to z
let me make that clear that is an r
right over here
and then we have the k component and the
k component's actually the easiest
because it's just 1 here so it's just
going to be 1 times and i'm just doing
that same color 1 times the partial of q
with respect to x minus the partial of p
with respect to y and then finally we
just have this d a over here and this d
a is multiplied by everything so we'll
put some parentheses and we'll write d a
so we're done we've expressed our
surface integral as a double integral
over the domain of our parameters and
what we're going to do in the next few
videos is do the same thing with this
using green's theorem we're going to see
that we get the exact same value